for the very first time it truly feels
like zero covered is actually on its way
out now the 10 measures uh that were
released today by the government there
are some things in there that might be
considered slightly more common sense
things like a strict ban on blocking
um Escape Routes or Emergency Services
being given access in the name of zero
covered but other things are extremely
fundamental and really amount to what
feels like quite a major dismantling of
some of the infrastructure around the
zero covered regulations so for example
the health codes that everybody has to
scan when they want to enter any public
place they will not be needed for most
venues apart from things like hospitals
and Care Homes and places like this okay
I just want to show you where I am this
is what's being called a field hospital
or a cabin Hospital these are these huge
uh places this was actually previously
an Exhibition Center on the outskirts of
Beijing that have been converted into
these major quarantine centers and we
think the patients themselves people
have either tested positive for covert
or have been a close contact are within
the Exhibition Center itself and these
little cabins that you can see in the
foreground here are actually where the
workers live but you know if you test
positive or even come close to somebody
who has you could be expect to be carted
off to one of these for potentially
weeks on end that also gonna come to an
end apparently people able to quarantine
at home it feels like there's no going
back and that zero covered it feels and
I say I promise it with it feels and the
maybes and the it seems because it is
China you never quite know but it feels
like zero covered might be on the way up